good morning John Katherine and I have
been getting up at what I consider to be
a sort of evil time of the day every
morning for the last couple weeks and
going on a walk I find this to be
wonderful we get to talk about what's
gonna happen today what's bugging us it
gives me time to think about big
decisions or new ideas or just sing
songs to myself or outloud whatever
every morning oh there's a different
song in my head and I find this to be
true all the time actually Inc Rocky
Horror Lambchop maxbox 2000 is there's
always one there why is that why is my
brain set up for there to always be a
song in it just waiting for me to like
check it and see like what is it right
now Oh Bonnie Raitt let's give them
something to talk about anyway I really
like doing this thing it has made my
life noticeably better I'm less stressed
out and the Sun rises can be pretty
great but every morning when I get out
of bed to put on my long underwear on
and jump into the frigid pre-dawn
Montana air there's nothing in the world
that I want to do more than get back
into that warm soft bed I live an
amazingly pampered life there are
hundreds of people all around my town
who will for small fee a make food for
me and then clean up after me there are
several different holes in my house that
hot water falls out of whenever I want
it to and for the last eight years or so
I've had a job that allows me to get out
of bed whenever I want and so I have
slept in the majority of those days I
have pretty good evidence that staying
in bed does not actually make me happier
or feel better so every single morning
the question is pretty pressing and do I
do the thing that will make me happy
right now or the thing that will make me
happier in the long term not even that
long-term really we're talking like like
20 minutes from now and remarkably it's
really hard to do the thing that will
make me happier 20 minutes from now and
for the entire rest of the day because
me now doesn't care about me 20 minutes
from now I just want to get back at the
bed I've also been thinking about this
ever since I made that video about
vegetarianism and how I am NOT a
vegetarian despite the fact that I
should be and I know I should but I've
gotten a lot of messages saying dude
suck it up Dumbledore said it himself
you got to choose between what is right
and what
is easy or something like that and I
feel yet vegetarians who were mostly
very nice and sometimes not at all I
have no scientific evidence for this but
sometimes I feel like you can only do so
many things you don't want to do before
you just accidentally eat a whole ice
cream cake I'm amazed by some people's
ability to do hard things all day long
forever particularly parents I don't
know how how this happens I'm amazed by
you it's hard to do the hard thing it's
why they call it the hard thing and it's
harder for some people to do the hard
thing than others and it's harder at
some times than other times like Ivan
have it sad times lately despite the
fact that there's going to be a new
Harry Potter book and also we confirmed
the existence of gravitational waves
which are like two of the hanky asti's
ever I mean not even I talk about why
I've been having sad times because it's
too sad so I'm gonna put it in the
scripture but I do know that what I
should do are the things that help me do
the hard thing more showing myself every
morning that I'm happier because I did a
thing I didn't want to do working on my
ability to consciously be having a
positive effect on myself and also on
the people in the world around me is
really important and I always want to be
driving toward that but I also don't
want to hate myself when I mess up and I
have no tips for how to not do the easy
thing in any given moment except to just
do it and not let your conscious mind
get too caught up in that decision
because man it's good at rationalizing
and being like you know you can go back
to bed don't worry about it just I'll be
you can get up in about 15 more minutes
by which I mean two and a half out just
jump into that cold pool the thing you
don't want to do and if you can't don't
be too hard on yourself John I'll see
you on Tuesday